welcome to this video when playing
playing playing new town new tar from
the Netherlands and right pling us a
night off didn't do that too often with
a form
he form that sure not sure how to keep
it within no no he's mixing it with
Bishop c4 interesting I wanted I didn't
really want to go into ski van ingen
with Bishop e2 not that it is terrible
or anything but I wanted to stay more
within the night off I'm territory but
now he is mixed systems and played
Bishop c4 let's see I what I i I'd like
to take and play Bishop c6 if i play e5
and play Knight takes e4 what is the
compensation not not clear
yeah I think you just blended Yvonne
it's not not so easy anyway because I
have the sum square on d5 and the
backward youporn so it's not an easy
technical winform by any means okay is
trying to stir up trouble with the f
porn understandable how to how to defend
this you can play a fire for me at five
f 4 ok let's drop this packet for the
first and two now see what to do Queen
c7 Ben Bishop f6 many important this not
to spend ages here and for too far
behind on the clock
hmm I never looked at this one but it's
not logical at all opening up against f7
porn hmm yup this is quite interesting
poor
hey Bishop f6 he will simply take and
with good reason
hmm really really problem ok I know it
just looks this looks look strange but I
don't want to weaken the King side at
the moment and jam this keeps up seven
defender
hmm
how to play that difficult I could try
King edge aid if it takes now on on f7 I
can takes it to at the end the intention
is of course to play the f-bomb oh he
didn't react to that at all okay let's
do that f6 of course this is a big piece
now on be 358 should help to release
some of the pressure bhakti ain't now
his back rank is also also bid week I
should use that somehow not sure how
you
hmm don't see a movie at the moment this
is not ideal
Bishop c5 he can probably take and play
up the aid
but then I have Queen a5 with Queenie
one mate yeah tricky very tricky
position
takes Queen TX rock d8 Queen 85
threatening the rook and mate I hope
that this is a valid defense if he needs
to play a slow move then I can actually
drop back and try to untangle I need to
play a move like h6 badly to not turn
have this back rank issue all the way
yeah I think I think this is actually a
good good defense now
the exchanges and Roxy 7i have a bishop
c6 and this is fine very fine actually I
have rope dat too i'm down to 37 seconds
this is actually the most difficult
thing here oops yeah passive but i need
to do this at the moment
check
check yep 22 seconds time morning
position is so I think winning but it's
not much time
now it's not so easy to go into pre move
mode can always check my work or play
any crazy move
f43 next check
check check check check check check
check check check check white forfeits
on time wow I really need to keep my
breath at the end one second we yeah
well this was this was very tough
winning this with nothing on the clock
yeah i mean i want this pawn but he had
he had some activity and I really
underestimated this capture with the
pressure now on f7 yeah well the
compounds to play Bishop f6 but hey this
is this is simply very tricky yes I'd
saw i saw this but i wasn't really sure
this is so great what i actually didn't
see us I have a big counter play with
roop g8 coming yeah then this is
probably the right one to should have
six if he cannot sacrifice then but wait
this is interesting yeah it doesn't feel
right to allow that to be honest here he
can get a big big attack with Luke f3
intending rook aged three years well I
guess yeah computer it's very optimistic
about white here yeah well the way it
was played it was also very tricky but
this was very important Queenie five
yeah and now I think I'm in control this
was bad Bishop c6 as much better yeah I
think this should we should be a winner
really four against two i get i get two
passes he can defend more tenaciously
but it should be a win alright thanks
for watching